it's a plan one county commissioner says
will make the strip safer that change
could be defining those pedestrian
overpasses as crosswalks tonight joe
mueller shows us what that change could
look like
i have people
i mean from the
me down there and they like it on this
busy friday
jose cuckernal is performing for all the
visitors
he either finds a corner that works or
performs on the pedestrian overpasses
for now how are you going to stop people
from making a living a potential change
could be on the table soon to officially
define these overpasses as crosswalks
that means no more performing or
loitering they would be used for walking
and that is it i feel sorry for people
that really depend on this this is they
live in this and they can't get a job
nowhere else so they do this tuesday
county commissioners will take a look at
a presentation on the idea you can't
stay in a crosswalk so we're trying to
come up with a way that we can legally
make sure people move county
commissioner tick sigerblum says it's
all about public safety especially after
a recent deadly stabbing of a visiting
off-duty police officer just weeks ago
on a bridge we just can't tolerate
people out there committing sex acts and
shooting people and shooting drugs it's
just unacceptable from playing music to
selling items or asking for money
visitors say they have noticed it i
don't want to feel threatened when i'm
walking across the road lisa worgerland
is visiting from canada she understands
the idea but says it could create other
issues it probably is a good idea to
have it just as a crosswalk but then you
have to also
probably give an option for these people
because they're just going to move
to somewhere else
joe mohler live local now